When Joe Biden and Democrats were able to
pass their one point nine trillion dollar
covid relief bill, there was some news
that tax reform might be Joe Biden's next
big legislative goal. And we talked last week
about what is expected to be in that tax reform
plan. We talked with Bill Share about the
political feasibility, remembering that
there are many Democrats who don't necessarily
support all aspects of what Joe Biden wants to do
from the standpoint of tax reform. But now it
looks like it may not actually be tax reform that
Joe Biden and his administration tackle next.
There's a report from the Associated Press
that it may be a very large a three trillion
dollar, I guess we're calling it an infrastructure
package, but it's really like an infrastructure
schools and families package. And Joe Biden
reportedly Monday met with Senate Democrats to
start laying the groundwork for what would be
a spending package that would deal with
many aspects of American infrastructure
that are sadly outdated. We've needed like real.
I don't mean you drive by and that stretch of road
near your house is under construction for two
years and it's never really clear what they're
doing, but eventually it gets done. And now
I'm not talking about that. I'm talking about
major repair and replacement of significant
American infrastructure. We're talking about
new development of roads. We're talking
about a refreshing hospital infrastructure,
green energy systems, you know, a lot of these
different things. And reportedly, this is exactly
what Joe Biden is looking at next. Three trillion
dollars in total. And it will include money for
schools. It will include money for families.
And it would be divided up. Could be a third,
a third, a third. Again, this is all early, but
it looks like it could be about a trillion dollars
for roads, bridges, rail lines, electrical vehicle
charging stations and a cellular network. And the
idea would be start pushing towards clean energy,
but do it in an in an economically competitive
way, which is what we've been saying for all
all this time. The idea is not necessarily to
take things out of the market, but it's let's have
fair markets where we're not subsidizing the wrong
things. The second piece of it, which is
the school piece, would include investments
in workers by providing free community college,
universal pre-K prekindergarten and paid family
leave. Another aspect that we've been talking
about for a while, which many on the right see
as, quote, handouts. Remember, it's our tax
money that's then being being used for programs
to call them handouts is wrong fundamentally. But
it also ignores that when you're doing something
that allows people to be more economically
productive, it should fit under the umbrella
of what the so-called free enterprise people would
also want. Now, that three trillion dollar number
is obviously a number that is going to lead
to the predictable and and regular refrains
from the right. And I think that hopefully
Democrats will realize we're not going to get
votes from Republicans anyway. So let's not care
about the fact that they're going to talk about we
don't have the money, where's the money going to
come from, et cetera, et cetera. They're going to
do that regardless. They would do it if it was two
trillion. They did it with 800 billion when it was
Barack Obama's spending program. They're going
to do it regardless. So hopefully that's not
something that is going to be affecting the way
that Democrats go about this. And fundamentally,
as I said, when when Donald Trump lost and
remember, we knew that on November 8th of 2020,
we didn't have to wait until January 20th to
know that. I said these two years will be a test
in two ways. One, can Republicans obstruct
everything and still get themselves reelected?
The answer may be yes. And we'll actually talk
later today about how even though every Republican
voted against covid stimulus a few weeks ago, one
third of Republicans, Republican voters think that
their Republican elected officials voted for
covid stimulus. So they may be able to obstruct
and not get punished by their voters because their
voters are so clueless. That's number one. But
number two, it's a test of what can you get done
when you have a two year period with the White
House, the House and the Senate? We've seen these
periods before. And we the infrastructure spending
needs to happen. It's been necessary for decades.
We are able to count on zero Republican senators
to vote for it. Their efforts will be obstruction
because ultimately. They are cult members,
they turned over the party to Donald
Trump when it became clear that
Trump had the momentum and even if privately
they were opposed to what Trump was doing,
they stood aside, I guess, because they wanted to
get their judges done or whatever the case may be.
And I know that one of the talking points
they may come up with and and unfortunately,
this one resonates even with some in my audience,
will be three trillion dollars for all of this
different stuff. Why can't we just separate it out
and do individual bills up and down votes on each
of these elements? And then it would be clearer
what people are in favor of or against, because
you can always have Republicans saying, well,
I'm not against doing some of this stuff, but
we can't do all of it because of item number one
and item number seven and twenty. Those are pork
or those are bad or whatever the case may be. What
you have to remember is that bills typically need
60 votes, but you can get around that through the
budget reconciliation process. But you're limited
in how many times you can use that process. Once
we know and we know that Republicans will not
actually negotiate in good faith, they'll find if
you change how you do the bill, they'll find you
new ways to oppose it. What you have to understand
is that reconciliation and doing this with
50 votes plus Comilla is probably the only way you
get it done. If you separate this out into four
or eight or 12 different bills, Republicans will
then just find ways to delay each individual bill.
They might use different justifications or
the same one. The only way you really have
a shot at getting this done is by doing it
all together in what's called an omnibus bill
and passing it through budget reconciliation.
So ultimately, they would say Republicans, oh,
break it up and then we'll do individual votes on
the merits of each one of these. Then they would
just obstruct and use delay tactics to make sure
that as few of those things actually get a vote
in the first place and then they would still vote
against it in the end. So I do think it's probably
more politically feasible right now for Biden
to do this than the tax stuff. That's that's a
political feasibility calculation. I think either
way, he's going to be doing it with literally zero
Republican support. If you think some
Republicans might vote for such a spending bill,
infrastructure bill, let me know. And specifically
let me know who, because I just don't see it